o gás só podem viajar em executiva tata
vamos lá estarão nos canhão para matar
tancredo e um história explosão
opte usual e que quem fala andar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
os pessoal nós vamos construir a coisa
mais ambiciosa que eu já construí aqui
no canal nós vamos construir um pneu
duro é tata é isso um canhoto que sei lá
o quê com ácido que eu não sei mas vai
dar muito trabalho tanto já de si muito
lá e aqui no canal e se vocês forem
novos que inscrevam também é só porque
vai dar fluzão vai dar meu pai há muitas
mudanças
se vencer pode furar uma batalha entre
nós construímos a nossa base é de batata
nós vamos precisar de muitos canos pvc e
vai ficar mais ou menos parecida com
isso não só vocês quiserem ver mais
vídeos deste já comentei isto é que
ganham de batata é muito muito bem mais
precioso que é preciso tubos pvc
material de segurança obviamente a outra
coisa pessoal não tem interesse em casa
até porque vai dar confusão nós vamos
mexer com gás com fogo com explosões
então faço e sempre na companhia dos
vossos pais do outro quem não faço em
casa sozinhos eu posso dizer que o
cientista e também todos os mesmos então
porque é que sejamos mais batata é isso
para ser o nosso projecto e esta batata
conhecem por isso ficando com toda a
velocidade eu acho que tinha uns mais
100 quilômetros por hora é muita
potência e temos também nós quer
convencional que o jato nem uma redenção
mas já fui explicar isso mas também
muita cola o nosso gasto vai ser o nosso
combustível mas com as ferramentas com
as quais eu sinto é nossa ferramenta
principal um cortador de pvc bom mas
essencialmente esse pessoal e agora
agora é só montar aqui o nosso querido
batatas bororó
mas bom você já não presta nem se vê
muito é no mundo do tubo mas eu vou
explicar como é que vai ficar vou fazer
uma montagem rápida essa vai ser a nossa
câmera de gás que o mundo vai ter que o
gasto acumulado que vai servir do
propulsor para a nossa batalha mas para
o nosso carro ficar aqui como lá eu
preciso tapar todas as entradas de ar
porque nunca vai ser em qualquer lado e
eu não quero isso quero que só saia
brito campo que é onde estava tatuando
ele vai ficar mais ou menos assim eu vou
colocar essa indução à equipa depois de
entrar na festa e logo a seguir empresta
depois entra o nosso tubo principal e
também vai ficar mais ou menos disse e
essa bateria traz que voltar para a
costa tanto é que eu vou entrar na nossa
batata e que mesmo por cima vou colocar
a nossa ignição que vai ser este quero
que eu vou tentar disputar o play e
quiçá e quando nós perdemos aqui me
escutam o gás vai explodir e como única
saída possível vai se esticando a corda
batata batata vai ser deflagrada
com muita velocidade eu vou tentar fazer
isso acontecer série mas eu preciso
muito do nosso porque só tem mesmo muito
líquido para dar muito trabalho
agora que você já percebeu um só vamos
lá construir então a nossa tão pessoal
vincular a primeira parte aqui do pvc e
não dos bulls especificar quais são as
peças porque esses foram os únicos que
encontrar porque dá pra fazer as contas
o que é muito melhor com uma quebra
muito maior e por isso não vos vou
recomendar que medidas nem peças porque
nem o próprio israel caiu tentei
improvisado ontem também você escolhe é
só colocar esta pensar que mais popular
nós precisamos escola de pvc cheira
muito mais tranqüila é muito tóxica só
uma coisa muito importante se vocês
forem ver as turmas do que não podem ter
nenhuma fuga de ar sem ser este quero
aqui por acaso se inspirar alguma fuga
de 47 anos pode ser que exclusão saía
por lá e nós não queremos isso o que eu
quero gastar e por isso querem para
disparar a matar então eu tenho que
fazer isso com muito cuidado e solar bem
enquanto esta copa seca que eu acho que
já desculpa disse que é muito rápido é
muito bom escola já que o ar é se os
parques todas e concluir a nossa câmera
gasto eu tenho claro uma por uma quebra
estar certo e não houve fuga para lá só
o próximo passo então é para que a nossa
quebra de caixa e para isso nós vamos
usar uma rosca destas quem seria esta
entrada feminina para depois colocar a
entrada machico isso vai continuar mais
ou menos assim ó e vai ficar
completamente suado lei
agora é só colar esta peça é do mesmo
jeito é só clicar aqui e agora inserida
que só esta é uma das partes mais
importantes senão a mais importante
porque se o gasto por aqui tampa vai
saltar e vai explodir por trás não é
isso que eu quero então eu tenho que
mudar esta parte muito
muito bem
outra coisa muito importante pessoal
vocês usarem estes o anc na rússia
porque vai estar esse lado nossa
quebra-galho então o sensei embora lá
vamos ver se funciona assim vai ficar
basicamente a cada disparo tem que abrir
as ruas que colocar o gás lá dentro
voltar a fechar a rosca e aí sim casar
na ignição sempre que eu queria esperar
uma batata vou ter que voltar a investir
a tampa
então é coisa mais importante que tem a
sua falta aqui é estruturado proteção
não pode haver sairá nada então vamos
ter para que este buraco olha aí ela só
a sua cola está muito vinculado então
próximo passo antes de colocarmos aqui o
nosso tubo porque vai trabalhar muito em
vantagem e vamos colocar a nossa emissão
nossos quero eu ainda não sei como é que
eu vou fazer isso mas eu vou improvisar
aqui
[Música]
acho que ele precisa mesmo se eu não vou
colocar a nossa exibição é que um de
marca ou lápis basicamente estamos quer
convencional que usa gás e tem aqui esta
pilha uma trilha que dá choque não se
conseguem ver essa edição é suficiente
para o nosso caso entrar em ação e
preparar a nossa batata muito rápido
o cachorro e que está só a nossa edição
está montada mas não só como ficou muito
bonita nossa base que nós quem é o que
funciona ou não se conseguem ver mas
pela fez 40 o próximo e último impasse
vai ser colocada então o nosso propulsor
o nosso que no nosso canon aqui na
frente mas o primeiro preciso cortar
aqui esta partida porque como vocês vêem
que estas e oriente ea batata não vai
conseguir entrar aqui mas de qualquer
forma vamos fazer que o corte porque ela
sim de perto melhor
[Música]
otto já que é que o nosso caminho mas
continua muito frágil eu já coloquei a
cola pvc já coloquei como aquele mesmo
assim ela vai um pouco então vai
reforçar com nossa fita amarela e preta
até agora ela só nós que lembra a data
já está pronto só falta um único
promoter era uma mira é o primeiro time
da emissora em 3d e isso nós vamos
conseguir a nossa batata para o nosso
alvo mas não só pessoal já que o ac
milan ea uma dobra olha isso quando eu
não quero usar é só baixar quando quiser
usar só vamos agora ela só chegou a hora
de fazer um de nossos textos lá fora
para a aacc entrou já entrou só podem
invejar temos aqui batatã e agora é só
empurrar muito bem até lá ninguém ficar
mais ou menos pura que assim aqui bem
perto da câmera de gás só que agora é só
seguir o nosso caminho com gasto e
disparar mil 18 muito cioso equipamento
de segurança em primeiro lugar para
alguns a luvas usar um capacete que não
é bem o que eu aceito mas protege muito
bem a cara e eu não sei se isso faz com
que isso vai fazer um barulho muito alto
então vou colocar também como proteção
para os jovens aparecem suficiente e ela
ofereceu qualquer lugar dentro de nosso
brazuca rock estava portando para uma
pessoa só tem a ganhar com gás eu tenho
um novo álbum também olha aí portanto
vocês vão ver onde é que eu vou acertar
eu vou tentar acertar o rebanho uma
víbora lapola psol primeira tentativa
vamos lá estar o nosso campeão de batata
ufc é o deus mãe
[Música]
por lapso a segunda vai tá lá no fundo
a lei do gás produção gás produção
isso é outro drama pessoal eu vou tentar
mais luz para colar pessoal 321 não
funciona agora o grupo som
meu deus obrigada a mesma hora só agora
nosso alvo vai ser o nosso homem amarelo
boneco de teste de experimentar freios
óleo que eu vou fazer é tirar mesmo à
queima roupa na cara dele vamos ver os
estragos que batata faz o gais 21
[Aplausos]
[Música]
não confio muito no estilo é esse o
tempo e não descubra só il-sung batata
como vocês puderam ver o pessoal não
aconteceu nada mas também eu acho que
coloquei pouco gás porque a batata não
se contentou força uma outra se o há
pouco aquela que foi paga por essa eu
acho que é mais 100 quilômetros por hora
não vou de conseguir outro bater essa eu
vou colocar mais gás e vamos ver o que
acontece por lá
vejam só como é que ficou voltada a toda
despedaçada não funciona
não dá outra mesmo é muito incerta mas o
cara é bom pessoal estava continuar a
brincar com a nossa música mas
infelizmente eu não consigo porque o vi
que alguma falha técnica e já não
resulta
se vocês tiverem alguma dica de como é
que eu posso melhorar o e pública
batatas 2.0 comenta e porque um dos
nossos comentários e vou tentar dar um
upgrade nesta suzuka mas é só foi bem
divertido sul umas três ou quatro vezes
então é ótimo no topo sul e agora vamos
lançar um desafio se nós conseguirmos
carols sem milagres neste vídeo e sim os
ambiciosos em milagre eu vou construir
uma similar por batata tipo mas tudo
batata mais limpa com muito alcance
então saiu da fila sob sol e esf quem
vai até a próxima semana
[Música]